[Musique]
bonsoir à tous bienvenue dans le 7-8
journal de tv 78 26 minutes pour faire
le tour de l'actualité locale tout de
suite les titres de ce mercredi 12
novembre à bord de leur tracteur ils ont
convergé ce matin vers versailles une
cinquantaine d'agriculteurs s'est
retrouvé devant les locaux de la
préfecture des yvelines
ces exploitants dénonce la forte
augmentation des charges notamment sur
les produits phytosanitaires le préfet a
reçu une délégation de manifestants
c'est un dossier d'envergure entre
maurepas elancourt le centre aquatique
intercommunal continue de faire débat
hier le collectif piscine pour tous et
mobilisé quelques minutes avant le
conseil municipal de maurepas ses
membres dénoncent un projet flou les
explications à suivre enfin elle
s'appelle eskimos c'est l'écho
laboratoire participatif accessible aux
saint quentinois cette plateforme en
ligne permet de prendre connaissance des
actions mises en place dans le cadre du
plan avaient climat air énergie lancé
officiellement hier
l'objectif c'est de s'adapter au
changement climatique et nous sommes le
mercredi 12 décembre ding
contrairement à ce que j'ai annoncé en
début de journal nous parlerons
également dans ce journal de deux autres
sujets la mobilisation lycéenne actuel
contre parcours sup et la réforme du bac
vu par les parents d'élèves ainsi que de
l'arc tiqui qui se tient en ce moment à
l'observatoire de versailles à
saint-quentin-en-yvelines la france de
nouveau touché par un attentat un homme
a ouvert le feu hier en plein centre
ville historique de strasbourg non loin
du marché noël faisant à à l'heure où je
vous parle 18h02 deux morts une personne
en état de mort cérébrale et 12 blessées
après l' attaque de nombreux
responsables politiques des yvelines ont
réagi sur les réseaux sociaux
s'attaquer au marché noël et symbolique
estime le président du sénat gérard
larcher le rambolitains affirme que la
france est engagée et dans la plus
longue guerre de son histoire
le député de la première circonscription
des yvelines didier baichère a tenu à
remercier les forces sentinelle engagé
en france l'assemblée nationale qui a
observé aujourd'hui une minute de
silence en séance certains élus avancent
des propositions les fichiers s pour
radicalisation doivent être déférés
devant la justice pour intelligence avec
l'ennemi
et mis hors d'état de nuire pour la
présidente de la région d'île de france
valérie pécresse libye noise valérie
pécresse même état d'esprit du côté de
pierre bédier le président du conseil
départemental considère que le combat
contre le terrorisme ne doit pas fléchir
enfin une réaction de la part du
président de saint quentin en yvelines
jean michel fourgous qui tout comme les
autres élus avant sa solidarité et son
émotion avec les familles des victimes
on prend tout de suite la direction de
versailles ce matin les agriculteurs se
sont rendus en convoi devant la
préfecture une action contre
l'augmentation des taxes ressentie dans
les exploitations en france est la
redevance devrait passer de 5 à 25 euros
par hectare les explications de michael
et demi d'euros les tracteurs ont
investi versailles ce mercredi matin une
cinquantaine d'agriculteurs venus de
houdan menthe et rambouillet venus
protester contre l'augmentation
programmée des taxes sur les produits
phytosanitaires en france des pesticides
visant à protéger les plantes des
parasites qu'il faut absolument que
l'agriculture française et les mêmes
règles cox et autres concurrents
européens
on a le droit de mettre les mêmes
produits phytosanitaires vous protéger
nos cultures pour avoir les bonnes et
les mêmes normes et pas de
règlementation française qui viennent
serait empilées on est en train de
courir un 100 m avec un boulet au pied
par rapport aux autres pays producteurs
européens
une délégation d'agriculteurs a été
reçue pendant près d'une demi-heure par
le préfet les yvelines jean jacques brot
l'entretien était jugé satisfaisant par
les manifestants je pense que il a
une bonne une bonne approche je sais pas
s'il a beaucoup de pouvoir et s'il va
pouvoir nous aider dans leurs
revendications mais ils nous montraient
une certaine solidarité avec ce qu'on
pouvait avancer une nouvelle action
devrait être mené en début de semaine
prochaine dans les yvelines le mode
opératoire n'a pas encore été dévoilé un
projet de centre aquatique intercommunal
qui fait débat hier soir mardi la ville
de maurepas signait le recours pardon à
la gestion est déléguée du projet lors
de son conseil municipal
un événement que ne pouvait manquer le
collectif piscine pour tous remontés
contre certains points du dossier
reportage de marie leygnac les chinois
depuis la décision de sa fermeture en
avril 2015 la piscine de maurepas pose
bien des problèmes à la municipalité le
projet de reconstruction d'un centre
aquatique intercommunal entre maurepas
elancourt à plusieurs points de conflit
le collectif piscine pour tous s'est
constitué en mai dernier
ses membres étaient présents mardi soir
pour manifester avant le conseil
municipal et tentaient de s'y exprimer
la concertation qui a été menée pendant
l'été est largement insuffisante la
concertation menée par les maires est
largement insuffisante elle est
lacunaire
elle est imprécise et elle laisse en
suspens de très nombreuses questions
pour répondre aux missions service
public des arguments incompris par le
maire de la ville qui a consulté les
habitants il ya quelques mois et obtenu
plus de 3000 réponse est fait avec mon
collègue d'elancourt et de coignières à
l'époque une grande concertation sur
plus de quatre mois entre juin et
septembre grand public avec un
questionnaire sur internet papier dans
les trois villes on a fait des groupes
de travail avec l'ensemble des
associations
on a fait des groupes de travail avec
les collèges les représentants des
collèges et des lycées
on a recueilli tous ses besoins
principal sujet d'inquiétude pour le
collectif partagé avec l'opposition la
délégation de service à une entreprise
privée
le maire de maurepas tient à rappeler
qu'il ne s'agit pas d'une privatisation
en dvb affaires publiques dans le privé
il y a toujours un compte rond de la
puissance publique qui ait lieu tous les
ans au travers d'un rapport du
délégataire qui est votée en conseil
municipal et ensuite vous avez les
agents de la collectivité qui suivent de
près l'exécution du contrat est une
obligation dans le cadre des marchés
publics le recours à la gestion déléguée
signé l'appel d'offres sera lancé le 17
décembre pour un lancement des travaux
fin 2019 le collectif se dit pourtant
déterminé à poursuivre ses actions et
appelle les citoyens à les rejoindre et
le collectif prévoit une nouvelle
mobilisation ce jeudi cette fois ci
devant la mairie d'elancourt le conseil
municipal de la ville votre a à son tour
cette délibération autre colère du
moment au niveau national les lycéens
sont mobilisés contre parcours sup le
service national universel et la réforme
du baccalauréat
luhan l union nationale lycéenne appelé
tiers à un mardi noir dans les
établissements un mouvement de blocage
suivi dans les yvelines notamment
attrapé montigny le bretonneux la
mobilisation a parfois dégénéré en
certains endroits en dénombre 21
interpellations dans le département on
parle de ce sujet de la mobilisation
lycéenne avec nicolas hardy bonsoir
bonsoir vous êtes le président de l'unap
attraper la verrière l'unap c'est
l'union nationale des associations
autonomes de parents d'élèves précise
que nous devions également avoir en
plateau un membre de l'ue enel pour
parler du des motifs de la mode
lisa sion et malgré nos sollicitations
aucun représentant des yvelines ne s'est
rendu disponible pour venir en plateau
du coup on va faire on va parler de
cette mobilisation vu par les parents
d'élèves quel regard vous portez vous
sur sur cette mobilisation lycéenne
les parents sont globales globalement
inquiet effectivement de la situation et
des éléments enfin la tournure que prend
que peuvent prendre les événements ils
comprennent enfin eu beaucoup
comprennent également la motivation de
leurs de leurs enfants qui sont qui sont
un peu inquiet olivier ils sont inquiets
ont parfois certaines mobilisations ont
pu dégénérer il ya eu des heurts avec
les forces de l'ordre et les parents
d'élèves sont dans quel état d'esprit
ils ont parfois peur d'envoyer leurs
leurs enfants au lycée ou non c'est à
dire ayant matin j'ai passé là
la matinée auprès des îles des lycéens
du lycée de la plaine de nobles tout
rappelé donc le seul ce lycée de drap ou
oui effectivement il ya une
manifestation vous globalement assez
s'est très bien passé donc pas eu de on
a pas eu de fin on n'a pas eu de raids
réel problème
hier à trappes vous parliez du lycée de
la plaine de nof où il ya eu un grand
feu de poubelles lundi qui ont endommagé
les grilles d'entrée du lycée
le fait qu'ils aient ces quelques
débordements vingt-et-une
interpellations dans les yvelines est ce
que vous pensez ne pensais pas que ça
dessert quelque part le message porté
par les lycéens le problème on le voit
on le voit depuis quelques semaines à
tous tout enfin même depuis des années
tous qui tout ce qui engendre toute la
violence engendrée par ces
manifestations qui souvent en marge de
ces manifestations
décrédibilisée dessert automatiquement
les les revendications précises c'est
pas la majorité des lycéens qui créent
ces débordements les visons d'abord si
je prends un exemple de
enfin si je prends le lycée de la plaine
de neauphle pour lundi c'est pas un
élève de ce lycée qui a qui a mis le feu
et alors une lycéenne de trappes qu'on a
interrogés justement devant le lycée de
la plaine de neauphle qui a tenu à
garder l'anonymat nous disait hier elle
dénoncé des violences policières
qu'est-ce que eyes et se ressemblent il
semblerait il semblerait qu'il y ait des
tirs 2
il semblerait non il ya eu des tirs de
flash ball et des lâches effectivement
c'est je peux l'assurer et également des
du gazage à la bombe lacrymogène alors à
gré des plaies des bonds a effectivement
fait a fait part d' est fait par
d'écarts de langage
oui comment après dans une situation
dans ces situations peuvent s'expliquer
oui les hommes en réalisant un
représentant du syndicat alliance me
disais en plateau que les forces de
l'ordre étaient faisait face en ce
moment à une situation compliquée et a
notamment le mouvement des gilets jaunes
donc un un climat assez compliqué en
france alors dans ce moment il ya eu
bien sûr aussi des des polémiques à
mantes-la-jolie on a vu ces images avec
une cent cinquante 150 jeunes
interpellés que l'on voit genou à terre
les mains derrière la nuque
ces images elles elles vous ont choqué
elles sont oui elles sont choquantes
elles sont choquantes alors on va on va
sortir du contexte moyennes surfaces et
des images qui font qu'ils peuvent nous
d'où vous nous faire des
des rappels à l'histoire on a connu ça
dans on a connu ça en france par par le
passé oui ça fait c'est choquant c'est
faire revenir vivre ça maintenant oui
c'est choquant vous faites référence à
des temps notamment de guerre vous est
tout à fait et sûre sur les
revendications alors nombreux lycéens
ont été notamment choqué que le
président de la république emmanuel
macron lors de son allocution lundi
n'est n'est pas évoqué cette situation
des délices et n'ai pas fait de
propositions ils sont pas choqués ils se
sentent ils se soient sentis oubliés
voire abandonner pour sortir de la crise
à votre avis et quelles sont les pistes
pour pour sortir de cette crise lycéenne
lycéenne alors je bandais effectivement
aux et 10 parcours suit pas c'est vrai
que parcours si pai a pris énormément de
temps à 20 par rapport à apb qui n'était
pas le bon système non plus mais
parcours super a pris beaucoup plus de
temps et beaucoup plus
enfin la procédure a été beaucoup de
plus longues voire beaucoup trop longue
pour pour les élèves
et est-ce que et on a un sentiment que
parcours sup travaille sur un élitisme
des élèves
donc pour vous il faudrait au moins une
inflexion sur sur ce sujet de parcours
sup à la jeunesse qui se fait pas
critiques issues à jouer il va critiquer
parce que je ne connais pas j'ai faim
j'ai essayé de suivre mais oui peut-être
toujours en tête rendre les choses quand
même plus simple merci nicolas ribes
d'abord être avec nous en plateau et
d'avoir décrypter comment voilà comment
voix 7
les parents d'élèves voit cette
situation je rappelle que vous êtes le
président de l'unap sur les secteurs de
trappes et de la verrière merci d'avoir
été avec nous ses autres mouvements de
contestation celui des avocats comme
partout en france les robes noires du
barreau des yvelines ont fait grève un
blocage du palais de justice et une
mobilisation aujourd'hui à paris motifs
des mécontentements le projet de réforme
de la justice adoptée en première
lecture cette nuit à l'assemblée
nationale est les avocats dénoncent une
justice est déshumanisé et éloigné du
justiciable écoutez l'interview du
bâtonnier du barreau de versailles au
micro de manon à baralle d'eau qui
explique ce que change concrètement ce
projet de loi le contentieux général
sera regroupé dans 2 au sein d'un
tribunal judiciaire du département
ce qui fait que le tribunal va être
éloigné des citoyens on va assister
également un désert judiciaire et les
citoyens seront évidemment décourager
sur un plan matériel sur un plan
géographique de saisir un juge et on
leur dira écoutez c'est pas grave
votre juges et à 150 km 200 km
qu'importe vous avez numérique pour des
petits geeti c'est à dire de moins 10000
euros ce que
le tour de ressort du juge
il faudra saisir ce dernier par la voix
numérique c'est à dire que pour une
certaine partie de la population qui ne
disposent pas ou d'ordinateur mais tout
simplement de réseaux l'internet
eh bien ils ne pourront pas avoir accès
à la justice
il a été adopté en conseil communautaire
le 20 septembre dernier le plan climat
air énergie territorial a été lancé
officiellement ce mardi à l'observatoire
versailles saint quentin
un lancement qui passe notamment par la
création d'une plateforme en ligne
baptisé eskimos afin de suivre la mise
en oeuvre du plan les explications de
nicolas landry eskimos le nom de la
plateforme en ligne du plan climat air
énergie territorial de saint quentin en
yvelines un outil virtuel destiné à tous
les acteurs du territoire pour permettre
l'accompagnement de la mise en oeuvre du
programme
les gens vous voir suivre de manière la
plus précise possible les évolutions de
consommation
ils vont pouvoir suivre aussi la mise en
application du plan climat air énergie
est également ils vont pouvoir proposer
des nouvelles actions
l'observatoire versailles saint quentin
va contribuer à cette plateforme dans le
traitement des données notamment de la
consommation énergétique
c'est beaucoup plus facile de demander
un certain un certain nombre de
personnes
de suivre leur consommation de dévaluer
leur consommation au quotidien à travers
un cadre un cadre d'évaluation qui
fournira avec une mini formation que
nous même d'aller chercher la donne est
donc ça ça responsabilise les gens par
rapport à leur consommation et puis ça
permet pour nous de recueillir de la
donnée fiable au quotidien faire émerger
une filière transition énergétique sur
le territoire ou encore valoriser les
commerces en circuit court
plusieurs actions du plan climat air
énergie territorial lancé ce mardi 11
décembre et voté le 20 septembre dernier
d'adapter le territoire aux changements
climatiques en essayant de à la fois
réduire les consommations d'énergie et
d'utiliser au maximum des énergies
renouvelables pour nous rendre le plus
indépendant possible par rapport aux
énergies fossiles et au nucléaire
on a des gros progrès à faire par
rapport à l'isolation thermique et là il
va falloir à travailler sur des
rénovations énergétiques de l'ensemble
des bâtiments depuis juin 2016 la
plateforme repères habitat permet aux
saint quentinois d'engager les démarches
pour une rénovation énergétique
c'est le colloque international sur les
changements climatiques et
environnementaux en arctique
l'observatoire versailles saint quentin
en yvelines propose l'arc tiqui qu'une
semaine de tables rondes interventions
scientifiques rencontres projections et
expositions bonsoir jean michel luc est
un bon soir vous êtes enseignant
chercheur à l'eau vs cul et au cercle
laboratoire culture environnement
arctique représentation climat de l'ue
vs q et vous qu organiser cet événement
avec alexandre à l'abri liées alors
pourquoi consacrer une semaine de
conférences à l'article alors parce que
c'est une région du monde qui fait de
plus en plus l'actualité pour pour de
nombreuses raisons pour parce que
d'abord le changement climatique et
visibles de façon beaucoup plus
importante que dans le reste du monde
notamment
au groenland ou que je connais depuis
vingt ans j'ai vécu comme au groenland
ces chèques faisait observer sur place
c'est quelque chose que j'ai pu observer
grandeur nature si je puis dire
depuis vingt ans j'ai vu la banquise
reculer j'ai vu les activités des inuit
être modifiée par ce changement et j'ai
aussi observer leur leur capacité à
s'adapter à cette nouvelle situation et
du coup quels sont les objectifs d'un
tel événement c'est réfléchir autour de
ces enjeux du changement climatique bien
sûr on le sait aujourd'hui le giec sonne
l'alarmé depuis de nombreuses années
encore sonné l'alarmé
tout en disant qu'il est possible
d'intervenir pour l'illimité limité les
dégâts que va nous apporte déjà ce
changement climatique et tous les
changements environnementaux qui y sont
associés et est aussi moi ce qui
m'intéresse c'est de voir comment les
communautés humaines non seulement font
face à ce changement quelles réponses
elles peuvent apporter et est donc c'est
tout l'enjeu de cette de cette de cette
conférence mais de façon un peu
différente de peut-être des autres
conférences puisque la nôtre associe les
les chercheurs en sciences naturelles
les chercheurs en sciences sociales
sciences humaines et puis surtout les
communautés autochtones au travers la
présence
deux personnalités sibérienne de jeune
inuit du groenland
il ya l'aspect culturel de tout à fait
de la sibérie et groenland 22 toute
cette zone de l'arctique et c'est notre
notre particularité à l'observatoire de
versailles saint-quentin-en-yvelines de
travailler en transdisciplinarité comme
on dit c'est à dire d'associer toutes
les formes de savoir savoir scientifique
évidemment et de toutes les disciplines
et puis d'un autre côté les savoirs des
communautés locales et en ce qui nous
concerne alexandre à la vrille et qui
travaille depuis 20 ans en sibérie avec
notamment la population evenk
et even et moi même avec les populations
inuits au groenland est d'abord tous ces
savoirs de les prendre en compte ça ça
aide aussi à mieux réfléchir sur sur ces
thématiques du du changement qui met
alors c'est non seulement les prendre en
compte mais c'est aussi travailler avec
elle avec ces populations
on le fait depuis comme je les dis
depuis de nombreuses années pour
produire pour coproduire comme on dit
coproduire le savoir qui est aujourd'hui
nécessaire pour pouvoir s'adapter et les
choses sont différentes de celles du
passé où les scientifiques venait dans
ces communautés sans du tout regardez
c'est les gens qui y vivent mais au
contraire on a nous scientifiques nous
ne sommes pas 24 heures sur 24 365 jours
par an
sûr dans ces endroits ces communautés y
vivent
elles ont aussi un savoir qui a été
ignorée pendant pendant dix ans
aujourd'hui ces savoirs sont intégrés et
ses communautés participent à égalité
avec les chercheurs
on vous disiez tout à l'heure que
l'arctique c'est l'une des zones
peut-être là la zone au monde on le voit
le plus ces changements climatiques
comment elle explique on les voit plus
en arctique
parce que l'environnement l'environnent
pas d'abord parce que le réchauffement
est deux à trois fois plus rapide que
dans le reste du monde
et puis d'autre part parce que leur
environnement
je pense aux couverts de neige je pense
à la banquise la banquise que je que je
connais bien
eh bien on la voit reculer d'année en
année alors c'est pas une c'est pas un
recul linéaire c'est c'est un recul
tendancielle il y avait encore des
bonnes des mauvaises années mais la
tendance
l es l et au recul de ses de cette glace
cette glace qui est essentiel aux inuit
parce que sans cette glace ils peuvent
pas sortir aller chasser pêcher et puis
vivre leur culture parce que leur
culture donc c'est de vivre dans la
nature et de pouvoir profiter de ce
qu'elle de ce qu'elle offre et c'est ce
recul on l'a vu aujourd'hui on l'a vu
depuis j'ai même
de vue à ouman ac la petite communauté
où je vais depuis vingt ans des années
sans glace les anciens ne se souviennent
pas d'années de ce type où la banque qui
ce n'est même pas présent vous peuvent
même pas sortir de l'île en traîneau à
chiens pour pouvoir rejoindre le
prochain village ou pour pouvoir aller
chasser les mammifères marins qui leur
permettent de vivre pour terminer
l'entretien revenons au programme de
l'arctique week ça se déroule jusqu'à
vendredi qu'est ce qu'il faut retenir du
programme ya beaucoup de choses
il ya des tables rondes il ya des
expositions des projections également
beaucoup de choses qui sont proposés
selon un petit coup il y à il y à il y à
des expositions à la bibliothèque
universitaire il ya des expositions à
l'observatoire
il y a beaucoup de discussions je crois
que c'est le mot partage partage entre
toutes les sciences et partage avec les
communautés autochtones de l'arctique
qui sont présentes à notre conférence
est
on en est très heureux très heureux
d'avoir d'avoir de les avoir avec nous à
la fois pour partager leur savoir et
aussi pour partager leur culture au
travers de danse à travers de chants
qu'ils nous qu'il nous montre et c'est
un vrai bonheur et ça s'adresse au monde
scientifique c'est ouvert a atomisé
ouvert à tout le monde c'est ouvert à
tout le monde et j'encourage tout le
monde à venir
il reste d'al ala giron toute la journée
de jeudi et est celle de vendredi avec
vendredi soir un événement
extraordinaire ou peuple sibérien et
inuit seront seront présents pour
partager avec tous ceux qui seront là
tous ceux qui seront là et ça sera un
grand moment
comme il arrive très rarement on
retrouve le programme sur le lien qui
s'est affichée je rappelle que c'est
organisé par vous jean-michel temps
merci d'avoir été avec nous et ma
collègue alexandra la vrille et égale
merci merci de la cité vous êtes
enseignant chercheur a relevé ce qu aux
séries nos étudiants et nos étudiants du
master article te disent qu'ils ont fait
aussi un travail remarquable pour
permettre à cette conférence d'exister
le message est passé merci d'avoir été
avec nous après être restée pendant 25
ans à saint quentin en yvelines
le campus de l'institut supérieur de
l'environnement vient de déménager à ses
nouveaux locaux à versailles
l'inauguration s'est déroulée ce mardi
soir en présence du maire de la ville
reportage de mickaël millero le campus
de l'institut supérieur de
l'environnement été officiellement
inauguré ce mardi 11 décembre
cette école privée accueille chaque
semaine plus de 200 étudiants venus de
toute la france
la structure propose après le
baccalauréat des cursus en deux trois ou
cinq ans objectif préparer les étudiants
sur ce secteur porteur donc les
étudiants venant d'un point de vue a
généré étudié par exemple de matières
comme la biologie chimie la physique les
mathématiques l'environnement l'écologie
ou le droit de la nature le droit de
l'environnement et d'autres matière de
management autour du développement
durable et la rse tout ça pour des
débouchés pour s'occuper au sein des
entreprises des enjeux environnementaux
et de développement durable après être
resté pendant 25 ans à saint quentin en
yvelines l'école s'est installé près de
la gare versailles chantiers pour
continuer son expansion
je pense que l'institution à
l'environnement ça se marie parfaitement
avec versa et tout ce qu'on essaie
aujourd'hui de faire autour de cette
thématique qui est l'environnement et
plus largement aux qu'on appelle la
ville nature versailles c'est une île
qui est connu c'est une ville dont le
nom résonne dans le monde entier et je
pense que c'est un atout pour cet
institut qui a maintenant plusieurs
années d'existence mais s'être installé
ici l'année dernière près de deux tiers
des étudiants réussi à trouver un
travail avant la fin de leur cursus dans
l'école
l'établissement espère réaliser des
chiffres similaires pour cette première
année à versailles
et puis comme chaque mercredi notre
petit tour dans les salles de cinéma à
saint quentinois direction ce soir le
grenier à sel à trappes pour connaître
la programmation du moment c'est au
micro de patrick jacques de dixmude
[Musique]
vous retrouverez bientôt au grenier à
sel percute j'aime percute j'aime ça
sera vendredi 14 décembre à 20h45 c'est
la projection d'un documentaire sur le
groupe de musique perd plus de l'âme
d'une séance exceptionnelle il s'agit
dans les musiciens autiste qui viendront
sur scène après le film c'est un
partenariat avec la merise des
réservations sont font sur le site de la
mairie ce point com est le deuxième
événement au grenier à sel ce sera mardi
18 décembre à 20h45 c'est jean paul go
qui viendra prendre un tel écart infime
sur un jeune marocain qui découvre la
cuisine avec sa grand mère et qui vient
en france rencontrer des grands chefs
mais bien entendu il fera l'expérience
du travail précaire l'expérience de
l'immigration clandestine
des micros et tout ça se dévoile à cette
rencontre se fera en partenariat avec le
maroc
donc ce sera mardi 18 décembre à 20h45
pour grenier à sel
un plaisir à tuer
le couscous pour perdre c'est la fin du
set 8 journal retrouvez nous également
sur notre site internet et notre
application mobile dans un instant
nouveau numéro du 7-8 débat avec le
retour en plateau doré lire 11 une
question qu'elle posera ses invités
l'annulation de la hausse de la taxe
carburant annoncée par le gouvernement
et telle une mauvaise nouvelle pour la
transition écologique le 7-8 débat c'est
dans un instant la belle soirée avec tv
[Musique]